Remember when we talked about
the creative vision for Android?
One of the pillars was enchant me,
that feeling that the app
was made just for you.
Joanna makes a good point.
Right now,
Sunshine is pretty basic in this regard.
Setting your location isn't exactly
customizing it just for you.
It's just basic functionality.
So what can we do?
Ideally we'd want something visual,
that impacts the whole application.
In fact, our weather icons,
which are used throughout the app,
are perfect for this.
What better way to customize than allow
users to change the very way they
see the weather.
So let's add the ability
to change icon packs.
We'll keep our APK size small by
downloading the images from the Internet
using our current included
icons only as a fallback.
Oh, we actually haven't
talked about downloading or
displaying images from
the Internet at all.
Well, let's start there.